[Music]
and welcome back to an exciting episode
of the careful boys
careful it's safe ladies and gentlemen
you know uh we were just having some
really really deep talks and
conversations with each other just
really getting to know each other it's
really kind of cool that we have this
escape retreat where we can really bond
and one of the things that bart wanted
to know about everybody was everybody's
worst [ __ ] stories this actually started
because uh
me and nick just finished working out
and then we came out and then uh you
said you had the most horrible [ __ ]
story it's tiff and i'm like
whatever [ __ ] story you have right
it's ten times worse when your
significant other is involved and i'll
be like holy [ __ ] and i'm like save it
for off the record no
did you guys end up talking about
someone's gonna take a shower what the
[ __ ] is off the record
careful boys the [ __ ] is off the right
yeah
there's an old segment to be a part
about hey careful boy
so this story is not like
it's more embarrassing 100 to me let's
use the word empowering empowering
that's where it's supposed to be yeah
exactly so
this is all tiff story this is from her
point of view
i wasn't in the room at all it's tip
[ __ ] story it's
and she's blaming it on me that's
there's that's one aspect of the story
that we could talk about vantage point
where you start with a different exactly
but it's mostly from this point of view
so
apparently she comes out she goes into
the bathroom after i just left the
bathroom and this is i guess she was
like cleaning the bathroom or something
or she found something on the floor and
it was like a little ball
just a small time it's already the [ __ ]
the story is like quick man dude this is
it this is it and we have enough time to
go around to everybody she finds a
little ball on the floor and she's like
what the [ __ ] is this
is that a cuckoo ball she picked it up
she picked it up she didn't know what it
was she's very trusting that was a [ __ ]
ball you're a [ __ ] ball you take goat
shits yeah that's how rabbit [ __ ] more
like rabbit yeah greatest of all times i
don't and she said circle pellets and
she said it was a perfect circle so this
is not in the bathroom right this is in
the bathroom oh okay it's like finding a
pearl from an oyster she picks it up and
she looks at it she's like what the [ __ ]
is this and then she smells it oh my god
and she goes oh that's poop
you guys are [ __ ] close your [ __ ] is
that unidentifiable visually it means
you're close bart
[Laughter]
i have never
smelled jill's [ __ ] and now he wants
dude that's [ __ ] close he's not that
close to her now he knows that yeah you
guys need to share that intimacy yeah
exactly i need to work on your
relationship you're not a perfect
spherical thing that brought curiosity
into the equation one i don't care what
shape it is you know people that go like
pretty much i'm gonna like go on a hot
air balloon ride with my significant
other or i want to go on a ayahuasca
trip to get close i'm like you probably
skipped the [ __ ] smelly
hey barn i'm gonna guess that gio's poop
smells like poop
i think you just move on but it's like
geo doesn't poop
what she shits
[Laughter]
she'll be pooping after carrying
barbecue she got ibs all the time
anybody has ibs
she's not here to defend herself
she can't say anything nothing about
nicki minaj he's like geo shits up her
own back sometimes
yes i carry her to the bathroom [ __ ]
sometimes i go to the toilet and the
whole seat has a large street going down
to the [ __ ] bowl do you guys blow out
to their yoga pants
so how did you how did you have a
comfort like what was the conversation
so she goes hey i found a piece a small
ball of poop in the bathroom
and she goes
like she and then she asks me she goes
don't you get naked before you poop
and i go all the time what do you mean
naked before you sometimes you take
everything off yeah dude i do the same
thing because why
regardless of the shower you get blood
naked
only when i'm going to shower afterwards
and i guess in this instance i was i was
like yeah i did i did get but in her in
her mind she thinks i always get naked
before i poop okay and she's wrong which
is kind of right though she's kind of
like did the poop fall out before you
[ __ ] i don't know i don't even know it's
mine but we'll say it is how many people
how many people share that bathroom
though it's just me and her and there's
no pets she thought it was the dogs that
came over but we had just moved in this
is like when we just moved in with each
other this is like maybe like the first
two months you just moved in this is
what you did
i guess so when you [ __ ] before you
shower you don't wipe right you just
like make a run for no no i wipe
um
but i don't i honestly don't were you
profusely farting before and you had to
you know i think i think that's what it
was something lodged out something
rolled out of the underwear squat into
the seat yeah so maybe something came
out but also it could have been hers we
have no proof this is her story was it
wet
no she said it was a ball a dry ball she
doesn't know if she's [ __ ] on the floor
she probably didn't she probably did but
this is me passing blame way to have her
back ready and it's speculation you know
just speculating that's cool that she's
still down there you know me i could
have showed the floor but i wouldn't
know
that's a great who done it yeah
you know that's really cool of her to
still be with you after all that yeah so
i'll i'll take the blame for it because
it's most likely let's be real it's like
like 80 20. when you were just in the
bathroom she came in to clean
i would guess that it was your [ __ ]
unless she came in to take a [ __ ] and
then clean or she framed me we don't
know we could be friendly we should do a
murder mystery game of who done the
shits and then like you start the game
yeah and everyone gets to go to the
bathroom and see the balls of [ __ ] on
the floor and say wait what is that well
we know it's nick cause we don't [ __ ]
balls
i'll say this that was the first and
last time it's happening and it's pretty
easy to figure out you smell the mouth
and then smell the ass
that's how you smell the [ __ ] that's how
you know it's linked to who what are you
sure man well bart doesn't brush his
teeth so he's like it smells really
close no it's just the ass smells a
worse version than the mouth but if
that's the same like vanilla hits or
whatever it is it comes from the same
human way do you think that's wrong do
you guys think your [ __ ] like smells
[ __ ] yeah it does i hope it does isn't
that healthy i know it does
i think it's got that weird smell where
it's like you know this is gross but you
like it
yeah if you smell your dog's breath in
its own [ __ ] it's not the same it's not
it's not the same but also though like
the a pedigree it is i'd like to think
my [ __ ] is like clean most of the
time like it's not
like i clean it pretty well but that's
wishful thinking
everybody's booty hole stinks i go
knuckle deep sometimes uh knuckles
wait you put the toilet paper in your
ass
i think he puts his knuckle in the gas
like like a little dip dude just to make
sure it gets clean oh yeah
as long as your hand's covered in stuff
that's totally fine i feel like i'm very
thorough no soap at all dude you just
wheel out when you do that no
do you moan when you do that a little
bit all right i bite my lip a little bit
to kind of prep myself before i go don't
roll your eyes back and look at me like
that dude yeah just just a little bit
full [ __ ] story let's go ahead and move
on
yeah we're gonna move on from that [ __ ]
story to a new [ __ ] story
can we write can we rate it at least
how bad is that story that's not that
bad
it's not bad and it's not embarrassing
it's a whodunit yeah it's it's me it
might not be yours oh oh now you want
the now you want the credit yeah it's me
dude i'm the one that shits balls in my
[ __ ] house i am the man of the house
upgrading the ending that's just small
[ __ ] balls that's the thing no
it was [ __ ] me man [ __ ] goats and
rabbits and [ __ ] they [ __ ] pellets
instead of one logs why no i'm just
wondering because you know their [ __ ]
pellet feed looks like [ __ ] it does yeah
it does it really does i'm like why so
maybe that's exactly why
is it their intestines probably
something weird like that they got
circular intestines or maybe they're
regular shits but because their bodies
are so much smaller than ours it's
relative maybe
it's true maybe this just has
human-sized like adult human-sized [ __ ]
goats are bigger than taika is also your
son yeah he's a big boy too he's not a
normal four-year-old but it shouldn't
look like this
you should be proud yeah that's pretty
good
that's way bigger i was scared the first
time i saw let's go ahead and talk about
your [ __ ] story
the worst one i had it's kind of similar
in nick's where um shout out to sphere
now me and gio first started dating
small globe and this is like before uh
you know before it's like you you first
got comfortable but before the move-in
phase
and i forgot what happened but i got
food poisoning and i was staying over at
her place
was one of those and and she was working
like a corporate job so she always had
to leave at like 7am type of [ __ ]
and um so she left for the morning and i
had to throw up and yeah and i'm like
thank god she's not here but it's also
her bathroom
so i'm like her toilet would be like
here and then the bathtub would be over
here so i'm [ __ ]
like [ __ ] my brains out i would
throw up between my legs or like oh
technique throw up in the bathtub just
like bouncing back and forth because
circus act because i'm like okay i think
i'm ready to like clean up clean myself
up and go take a nap you know so i'll be
in the bathtub with the hot water
running and i'm oh [ __ ] no i'm not i
gotta go [ __ ] you know when you have
like the crazy like food poison your
body can't make up its mind yeah so you
think it's over but it's not
and i'm finally sitting probably on the
toilet uh [ __ ] and throwing up for
maybe
maybe at least an hour and i'm like okay
cool i think it's chilled out i still
have a fever but i think it's chilled
out
so i'm gonna go in the bathtub and then
i'm gonna shower and then i'm just gonna
go to sleep and try to sleep it off i go
in the
shower turn on the hot water it gets all
steamy in there i'm just like letting it
like like wash me and it feels good and
then i'm like oh [ __ ] my stomach feels
funny
and then i push a little bit because i
think i was done so i thought i did the
little fart test and
boom [ __ ] diary just comes out and
when you're when you're standing up and
not in the toilet it comes down and it
kind of bounces back up so it [ __ ]
hits the bathtub
comes back up splatters on the wall and
i'm like oh [ __ ]
the whole [ __ ]
it smelled like someone's vaping
diarrhea
the whole [ __ ] bathroom smelled like
[ __ ] and then i'm like that's like dumb
and dumber [ __ ] now i feel so bad i'm
like washing and i take my bottle of
soap i'm also washing the walls
and then i'm like looking around and you
know like between tile there's [ __ ]
grout right
and so i'm like i don't need any
evidence of this [ __ ] so i'm
like looking for ah i'm like [ __ ]
trying to scratch it
just trying to get very thorough dude
yeah the whole the whole [ __ ] between
the tile
and then when i when i finally got clean
and i was and i felt good i went to go
uh sleep steep space right now it's
crazy and then geo is nice enough to
take use her lunch break to come back
from k-town to alhambra to check up
mommy
and then i was like [ __ ] should i tell
her
and i'm like the honest man always tells
closure right
not to tell her but it shouldn't judge
me or anything sadly that's cool
you talk about scraping the [ __ ]
ground with your nails
i was vaping [ __ ] in your bathroom
that's the worst part is the steam
oh it makes it so bad
dude some of the [ __ ] i had to [ __ ]
press into the the drain of the bathtub
because it's like sitting on there like
get get down there do you think do you
think bart's just sitting there
sometimes and he farts on his balls and
he's like oh [ __ ] i gotta go tell jio
[Laughter]
i gotta be straight up about this
full transparency when we started this
relationship we said we would be fully
transparent so i just farted on my balls
i felt them lift up a little bit
just so you know
wow that was definitely better than
nick's story i'm going to that's very no
judgment but some judgment like bart
should get a movie
i just get a limited series let's say
yeah yeah 90 minute babies 90 minutes
it's like 127 hours it's like a whole
it's like a hallmark christmas movie
no one's gonna watch it but it's there
it's there for you guys poor acting
it's on oxygen
that was like that was the worst
number 20.
what about you ryan
damn mine's
mine's very sad oh uh because because
this is like a feature film of [ __ ] dude
it's very obvious whereas as bart's was
very honest mine is like
a lie it's very much predicated on a
huge lie
so i shat my gown during my eighth grade
graduation
while we were standing up
on
church to waiting to receive our
deployment i'm not wearing trousers
underneath i mean i was but i mean
that's just to give you context of what
i'm wearing i didn't just [ __ ] directly
on the gown you're just dropping it off
like i'm getting ready to flash [ __ ] the
gown who says trousers
do you want to wear trousers
no it's um
british that's the real travis costume
designer for annie says trousers
the [ __ ] is with you dude
the [ __ ] is with you
don't you wear trousers
yeah
balloons
[ __ ] oliver twist on broadway costume
designers with us
jesus are you even telling this i've
never told this
uh within earshot of anyone who was
there which is like mostly people i grew
up with they never
knew until probably right now if you're
watching this wow you kept it a secret
yeah so i had the worst diary of my
childhood life at that very moment
i i just i just swear like of all the
farts you think are going to be farts
this was supposed to be one of those
and it wasn't and it was very quiet
diarrhea
and as soon as it happened i i remember
i was standing because we ought to stand
you mean you you thought you had a fart
and it just went
yeah but i didn't even try to fart i
just went okay that's coming out but i'm
not gonna even and then just went and
you're like oh that's warm
yeah and then
and then we sat back down and the whole
time my eighth grade graduate my family
is there everybody's there i'm on stage
like on the at the gym
all over your butt so much [ __ ] in my
pants and i'm just like how the [ __ ] am
i gonna get out of this
and it's really smells really bad it's
oh
yeah it's [ __ ] but nobody knew
you're you're revealing the secret right
now okay look the part where it becomes
a lie is that uh so
you put you know the kid next to you
[ __ ] yes
so like
got a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that's what
he gets dude
so basically
i try to get to the bathroom as soon as
possible and uh so you get your diploma
yay everyone's happy for you you [ __ ]
how did you walk up and accept it were
you just like small stepping away it
didn't matter i'm just gonna walk right
i can't get more [ __ ] in there it'll
just be in a different condition
but then it wasn't dripping off
down your legs so what i did was as soon
as we you do the the processional to get
out like to walk i [ __ ]
went for it my family's waiting out
there like yeah my whole family in the
lobby like like 15 people i just went oh
yeah i just buzzed right by him went
straight to the bathroom and i was just
there for maybe like 20 minutes trying
to wash and scrub and there's you're in
the bathroom with just like the [ __ ]
soap from the thing and yeah i'm in the
bathroom like you were like other people
are walking in the bathroom seeing you
with your [ __ ] pants in the sink aren't
they no no one's seen anything it's all
been contained like luckily but it's my
shirt is [ __ ] done because it was
tucked in
my shirt is [ __ ] done wow it looks
like a graphic tee now and then i'm just
sitting in there
and he shuts out his chest he's not with
a diarrhea what the [ __ ] am i gonna do
because right after this not only do i
have to say hi to my family and
everything but we're gonna go on a
[ __ ] limo ride
with all the eighth graders and we're
the the plan was we were gonna go around
like downtown and just kind of first
time in a limo and stuff and i'm like i
[ __ ] smell like [ __ ] so what i did is
i um
totally dissed my family by the way
until this day they [ __ ] don't
understand why i did that they're just
like you were very rude at your eighth
grade you didn't tell them i had [ __ ] in
my pants i never did i couldn't [ __ ]
call it that's why you're probably gonna
do
graduations are not about the kids
they're about your parents they were
there they probably have they probably
feel some resentment towards them i get
into the i get it to the limbo i smell
like [ __ ] the first thing i do is i go
this limo really smells like [ __ ] guys
nailed it nailed it and then uh they're
all like yeah it does like what's wrong
with this limo and then one of the girls
was like this is this is my my dad's cup
my uncle's company there can't be
anything wrong with it i was like it's
probably him it must be the driver am i
right
[Music]
[ __ ] your dad's company is terrible and
all the other kids all the other kids
are like you doubting all these kids are
like your uncles stinks
oh my god they're like your uncle
now she's embarrassed the rest of the
ride oh dude you have so many people to
apologize to [ __ ] every one of them and
and if he were
watching right now what would you ruin
his business or her or her i mean
can i take away this is a bunch of
little eighth graders but
uh sorry for that hey they grow up and
make money pal
i was the one who [ __ ] it was me
um yo three phone calls that's okay you
know i did everything i could to clean
up right your limo was fantastic you
know people say this show is about
[ __ ] fart and [ __ ] but what it really
is it's it's a segue to your heart when
you [ __ ] talk about [ __ ] you open up
not only do you open up your [ __ ] to
the world but you that's the vortex to
your heart
i can't believe this show gets sponsors
yup
[ __ ] thank you curology
skin care products
thank you depends
depends for children
blows my mind i didn't realize that was
gonna be so good that we might just need
a part two this is gonna be another time
we're just gonna have to leave it on
that because oh wow come on
there's gonna be something worse than me
sorry for the cliffhanger guys
this is a good bidet episode we're
[ __ ] judging eighth grade ryan and
[ __ ] yeah let's just say if you really
really well number one whoever's out
there
always lie because you can get away with
it for like 20 years just like right and
people forget what they're like they're
like
bart you know what happens is you turn
off the people that you love
dude can i ask you this though you're
sitting in the limo you know how
sometimes you don't mind the way that
your [ __ ] smells yeah are you in the
limo and you're kind of like fine but if
we're just
everyone's dressed all nice and [ __ ]
you're not mentally fine because of the
guilt yeah but sensationally it's normal
you're like hey pass me your water will
you
get it and then your friends around you
like it really smells around here like
yeah i guess
the whole time he's in the limo
he's complaining about the smell the
whole time he's doing a good job trying
to move around and make sure that [ __ ]
is everywhere he's permeating throughout
your uncle eats i don't really mind it
is that hey can you turn on the heater
full blast i should have been killed
this is pretty unprofessional that's
what he's saying yeah you know what you
gotta do is uh this thanksgiving you
gotta gather up your family you need to
you need to [ __ ] be like i have a
video i want to show you and you guys
sit around and you when you watch this
together and the video only shows nick
and bartholomew i told him
i told my cousin i told my cousin that
was there and then she was like no
[ __ ] way because i literally just
dissed they had presents they were like
flowers and i just [ __ ] i gotta take
care of this dream i [ __ ] myself
but i was like i was thirteen so i was
like when you're in eighth grade junior
high that's also like your most
sensitive like yeah because you really
think it's gonna matter forever yeah
you're you're dead forever live it down
you get a [ __ ] up haircut and you
don't want to go to school if you're
going from eighth grade to high school
and like that same class is going with
you and they didn't know
they would [ __ ] you up oh yeah it's over
it's like getting cancelled on social
media exactly yes the middle school
cancellation yo so i i lowkey encouraged
lying on that [ __ ] yeah
you